donc petite brocante de rien du tout tu
vois un dimanche matin et qui en fait ce
truc ça coûte que 10 balles quoi cher
journal j'ai un petit soucis je ne
retiens que les informations inutiles
quand je demande son prénom à quelqu'un
je pense tellement être attentive que
j'oublie complètement de l'écouter du
coup quand il me parle de son métier
j'essaye de me souvenir de son prénom
et quand il me donne son numéro je sais
ça s'écrit commentant prénom comme ça se
prononce
eh bien je lui assignant les magic lui
ressemble puis j'attends désespérément
qu'il passe un coup de fil à quelqu'un
pour l'entendre dire à l'eau commence à
s'équilibrer etienne où fabien et jérémy
je pas juste un coup de fil pour acquis
qu'après que je peux annuler alors ouais
comment ça c'est qui c'est moi le plus
con quoi aucun ami le croise par hasard
en disant hey salut antoine où damien ou
eric qu'est ce que tu fous là festif où
l'injure battre obama attend je te
présente son prénom c'est quoi déjà je
suis je là je retiens le prénom de son
pote et je le range dans les tiroirs
information inutile de mon cerveau aux
côtés de la référence de mon fauteuil
que j'ai acheté il ya dix ans deux
numéros de téléphone fixes de ma
meilleure amie en 98 et de celui du
petit mineur au cinéma aux côtés de la
référence des piles cr 243 que j'ai dû
acheter une fois dans ma vie alors que
je suis pas foutu de me rappeler si j'ai
besoin de piles aa ou de aa à aa
j'oublie que les stratagèmes que je mets
en place pour qu'il me redonne son
prénom
oui allô c'est qui lequel ne sont pas
toujours très concluant j'oubliais om à
droite et ma gauche
j'oublie lors des rendez vous importants
parce que j'avais pas de quoi noter que
je me suis dit mais t'inquiète c'est bon
on t'oubliera pas franchement 15h15 rue
de marignan ça s'invente pas allô oui
ouais ouais je suis là dans deux minutes
je suis en chemin la doua dans le métro
de trois stations quatre stations tête
schéma je tente pas très bien sa coupe
oui
[Musique]
je finis juste la page parce que je
pensais